okay maybe i'll play one fog of war game
because what is this okay
let's try it fog of war okay
i have no idea what's about to happen
all i know is
we can't see what's happening here
so
what are the rules even oxygen gambit
thanks for that more appreciation
bits also this is probably a terrible
thing to stream
if my opponent can my opponent can
actually stream snipe
the goal is not to check me but to
capture the king oh
oh but i can see in my territory
oh interesting
wait i'm so confused
it's weird i can highlight the square
but it also
okay they need to fix some of the code
okay so my opponent's moving things
hmm
i'm just curious like what happens if i
move into squares you can move to
oh interesting oh
ah i think i understand now
okay so i i should really
okay i have a strategy
this is still confusing oh my opponent
said hi hi
okay so i'm playing deadlocks
hmm
so i really want to just enable as much
vision as possible
yeah okay so i know there's something
here
let's enable this oh there's a thing
there too
interesting
i think what i'll do i want to draw
arrows but never mind
play this yeah i want to do this and
then
start pushing the g on
[Music]
the goal of the varian is to capture the
king
oh so there's probably something on the
e-file let's
let's be safe let's be safe
man i want to play queen e4 but it's
probably not a good move
yeah i'm gonna hide the king
[Music]
and we'll take this way okay so
it's very likely black has
black in that vision all along the d
file
play h3 maybe g4 coming
what oh there's a how how'd that get
there
i mean i guess i could take oh but
no there's there's not an f6 i know that
so i'm not subjecting myself to mate
so let's take oh
oh so i okay so i have to remember where
the pieces are
so i don't have six probably pawn on g7
oh there's a queen too
and the queen has vision
interesting okay
beginning to understand this a little
bit more
oh that means upon this pawn is
undefended probably
oh my king is slightly in trouble though
i have to be careful of like checks
let's take this
okay so the bishop is there queen is
there and then
oh that knight probably came from f6 i
assume
to keep track of what black has
a much better idea i just don't know
where the rooks are
oh the piece just disappeared
where could the knight have gone
probably back
probably back to f6 so the queen's on e5
i know that
[Music]
let's play
i just don't know where the king is
okay
wait what just happened
oh the pawn either moved to b6 probably
yeah probably moved to b6 actually
um i'm scared there's a rook on c8
if there's a rook on see it i could
i could run into trouble
hmm
i might be in trouble here oh my time
oh okay the rooks are also now i know i
know where all of black pieces are
um let's move this way oh the pawn went
to b5
okay
so rooks are connected so the rook ever
attacks my queen
then
i can just take it i think
my time
i can't pre-move either
my king does not want to be there
i want to pre-move
you should probably take the rook
i'm in trouble
i think
oh attacking the queen let's go but they
like my opponent probably knows the
thing is
oh this is
it's kind of intense
okay so i know the rook is there
man i forgot what happened with the
pawns
okay we're going to trade oh g5 was just
played
put the bishop on d5 because they don't
know i have a pawn on uh on e4
unless they do
uh-oh
wow i won dirty flag let's go
i won my first game ever a fog of war
can i see like the full game
we'll see the full game
oh i just want to see like all the
pieces
how could that work
i guess we see from both perspectives
man it's so trippy wow
so black was castle i don't know what to
make of that
that was interesting though oh sorry if
i gave anyone a seizure
the chad is saying shift alt f i don't
believe it but i'll try it
um shift
shift alt f
oh oh wow chat man
chad knows shift alt f shows the pieces
how do you know that wasn't intuitive
oh press shift alt f to toggle oh
chad is so smart okay let's see this
game
this was in english um
oh black played very reasonably this
pawn is probably hanging for a while
yeah casting is probably a good strategy
in this game
then yeah i was scared about e3 falling
but my opponent didn't know
like what was defending e3 because they
they can only see the pawn
and then they probably assume i have a
pawn f2
wait was my king hanging in the final
position
i won oh i didn't realize that
oh that's what my opponent was trying to
say they tried to take my king
but they were too slow oh it's so funny
because yeah they they know my king's
here because the queen's attacking it
oops wow
so i'm i'm undefeated i've never lost a
game of fog and
of what is this called fog war or fog of
war
even though i probably should have lost
okay i'll probably put this on youtube
youtube people you can try this
chess.com variants they have a lot of
new exciting
things to try i'm envisioning a
thumbnail where i
photoshop fog on top of the chessboard
and maybe on top of my face